the more primitive a man is
the better he believes himself to be
not always sorry for the one who was
wrong
asking forgiveness of the one who values
the relations
a man only begins to be valued
when he is no longer there
a woman who saves money on herself
makes men want to save money on her
modesty and conscientiousness
receive their reward only in novels
in life they are exploited
and then shoved aside
a woman becomes smarter when she is in
love
whereas a man loses his mind
[Music]
women do not need to explain anything
you always have to act with them
if a woman is angry
it means she is not only wrong
but also she knows it
if a woman belongs to another man
she is five times more desirable than
the one you can easily get
it is better to die when i want to live
than to live before you want to die
what you can't get always seems better
than what you have
this includes the romance
and idiocy of human life
strange how complicated we can make
things just to avoid showing what we
feel
to forget is the secret of eternal youth
one grows old only through memory
[Music]
there's much too little forgetting
he who wants to hold on to that is
losing
those who are ready to let go with a
smile
are trying to keep him
[Music]
whatever happens to you
never take it personally
nothing in this world is so important
i stood next to her
listened to her
laughed and thought how terrible it is
to love a woman and be poor
only when you finally part with a person
you begin to be truly interested in
everything that concerns him
this is one of the paradoxes of love
is a mistake to assume that all people
have the same ability to feel
a man is always great in his intentions
however
not in their fulfillment
therein lies his fascination
[Music]
there is nothing more tiring than to
attend how a person demonstrates his
mind
in particular
if there is no mind
[Music]
a person can become close to you in
three days
and the one who lives near you for years
may never know what your favorite color
is
the first person you think of in the
morning and the last person you think at
night
is either the cause of your happiness
or the cause of your pain
[Music]
a woman should not tell a man that she
loves him let her shining happy eyes
speak about this
they are more eloquent than any words
[Music]
only a complete idiot would argue with a
woman and appeal to her logic
a lonely person cannot be abandoned
[Music]
being in love is when you want to get
old with someone
[Music]
i feel like i am among people who are
going to live forever
at least that is how they act
they are so obsessed with money that
they have forgotten about life
which quote did you like the most
share your opinion in the comments one
day you will regret that you did not
hear these quotes earlier do not lose
the opportunity watch our next video